[Musik]
hallo was geschah wirklich in jena
nebligen novembernacht als jamaika starb
welche rolle spielt der israelische
geheimdienst wann genau hat peter
altmaier die letzte pizza quattro von
marie bestellt und ist die fdp wirklich
ganz alleine schuld rekonstruieren wir
mal die abläufe
wer war besonders gemein zu wem und wer
hat als erster angefangen zu heulen
gut das letzte beantwortet sich von
selbst
[Musik]
das ist fast die nach sehr gut zusammen
machen es uns aber nicht so einfach
oliver wer die wahrheit will muss tiefer
graben was wenn angela merkel selber den
tod von jamaika wollte
[Musik]
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn
das weiß eigentlich müsste die kanzlerin
am boden zerstört sein
aber dann erklären sie mir doch mal
diese aufnahmen
kann ich erklären
hallo
man kann das oliver niemand aber meine
ganz andere frage kann es vielleicht sei
das aus der ehemaligen spaßpartei fdp
klammheimlich eine rechte spaßpartei
geworden ist
[Musik]
die fdp ist das doch quatsch ach ja
sogar die csu sagt die liberalen haben
uns in der flüchtlingsfrage rechts
überholt und man kann die csu gar nicht
rechts überholen
lindner dieser verteufelt gut aussehende
pfiffikus hat einen neuen markt entdeckt
sachen sagen die rechten gefallen aber
schöner formuliert ich hatte
beispielsweise vorgeschlagen den
familiennachzug im sinne des
spurwechsels neu zu regeln dass also
menschen die für ihren lebensunterhalt
sorgen können
in der lage sind den familiennachzug zu
organisieren
genial flüchtlinge mit arbeit die uns
nicht auf der tasche liegen dürfen ihre
familie nachholen
sie müssen es halt selber organisieren
verstehen sie das wirklich alles drin
wovon nationalliberale feucht werden
das geht gegen ausländer und gegen arme
ja und der beste beweis ist die reaktion
der afd
opa gauland erkennt sofort wenn einer in
seinem garten wildert wie der lindner
er ist dicht an der afg an den
kritikpunkten der afg flüchtlingspolitik
rechtsstaat aber wir sind das original
deswegen ist er keineswegs sozialen
bessere hälfte die bessere fce
tschuldigung da lacht er aber in
wirklichkeit hat er todesangst neue
konkurrenz ist in der stadt wie soll
oper gauland mithalten mit so viel style
und sexyness er wird es natürlich
versuchen klar welche ironie wenn die
afg ausgerechnet wegen der liberalen
stimmen verliert dann wäre die fdp zum
ersten mal für was gut glaube ich nicht
wirklich weiter bei damen und herren
[Applaus]